somebody calls me Grandpa at the park
I'm walking away I'm not responding to
anybody calling me Grandpa papa papa any
of that Papa yeah I'm not responding I
will pretend not only will I pretend
like I don't know the kid I will be
aggressive towards the child I'm not
responding to Grandpa my kids are
calling you Grandpa not if they want to
come to my house or not just so you know
your grandpar your grandparent nickname
will probably shift throughout the years
no dude they get to everybody's going to
call you the same thing we'll see so
your mom picked BB which I thought was
great starts with B easy to remember BB
and he said to me what do you want your
grandfather name to be and I said LeBron
see that doesn't even start with Jay
though doesn't matter dude but Mom
started with the B doesn't matter LeBron
how how who doesn't want to go to BB and
LeBron's house you're white there's are
you saying that a guy a white guy can't
be named LeBron I'm saying have you ever
met a white guy named LeBron no but I've
only know of one person named LeBron